Now it is time
for tonight's #HashtagWars.
-(cheering)
-Yeah!
From Donald Trump calling
Jeb Bush "low energy"
to Donald Trump caught on tape
bragging about sexual assault
to Donald Trump becoming
the (bleep) president,
2016 featured news stories
as insane and unbelievable
as Donald Trump.
Will 2017 be
anywhere nearly as eventful?
Only time will tell--
we'll have to wait and see.
Or will we?!
Let's all...
gaze into our crystal balls
with tonight's hashtag
#2017Predictions.
(villainous chuckling)
(cheering)
-Yes.
-RICHTER: Nice.
My first prediction
is that this (bleep) guy's
not going anywhere.
Uh, other examples might be...
-(whooping, applause)
-Oh, stop it!
You say that here, and then
you'll go on the Internet
and tell me
how much come I eat on Twitter.
-Uh...
-(laughter)
I... That's for you.
(laughter)
So, examples of this might be--
Apple swings the other way
and adds two
headphone jacks, or...
It'll finally be a wrap
on planet Earth.
I'm gonna put 60 seconds
on the clock, and begin.
-Diona.
-Black Twitter finally becomes
-a separate but equal app.
-(laughter)
(whooping, applause)
Points.
Matt Besser.
Trump resigns the presidency
to take over
the Trump impression on SNL.
-All right, points.
-(laughter, applause)
-Diona. -Planned Parenthood
changes its name
to Figure It Out Yourself,
You Dumb Slits.
-All right, points.
-Whoa.
Andy Richter.
Uh, Jimmy Fallon tousles
Putin's hair
and gets his hand dunked
in acid.
-All right, points. Points.
-(laughter)
Matt Besser.
Kanye West completes
a full concert!
-Yeah, points.
-(cheering, applause)
-The whole thing.
-It'll never happen.
Diona.
Jay Z releases
his follow-up to Lemonade
-called We Were on a Break.
-All right, points.
-(laughter)
-Andy.
The first viable human clone
is produced.
It's a Chris Hardwick
that hosts a recap show
about all the other shows that
the actual Chris Hardwick does.
-That's a fantastic idea.
-Yeah.
-(cheering)